did you see that little kid that
Pentecostal kid recently they had a kid
who was doing
speaking in tongues he was a young
preacher now did you growing up did you
go to church we would sometimes my dad
would take us over there you know my dad
was so old when I was young when I was a
child and so he would walk over there to
church and he'd fall asleep he'd fall
asleep wherever we were yeah and so when
I got there I was kind of on my own
wherever we went you know my dad was
like I'll introduce you to people we go
we'd sit down for a second too we could
take a break and then he'd be [__]
dead asleep so then I would just be kind
of like in these places and I had this
sleeping father that felt uncomfortable
and then I was there and had to kind of
like navigate some situations that kind
of stuff would happen a lot with my dad
and how what kind of church was it was
it Presbyterian Presbyterian yeah they
had three nice oak trees I remember
and uh they try to do an insurance fire
once or twice but it didn't take and
and
[Music]
um
great breakfast over there though
right God nothing will bring you home
you know nothing I'm bringing to the
Lord like a dang one of those donuts
with pink frosting and uh think of like
different churches like you remember
like we went to this church uh in
Maryland that
uh just amazing you go and get pizza oh
donuts and you know you're like yeah
you're usually a little hungover on
Sunday and you're like this is sweet you
don't have a little kick from that
lemonade you're like this is perfect
yeah God knows what I need but I
yeah church was I thought the funnest
thing about church was just kids playing
and stuff like like a social environment
yeah you know and it used to be that was
the place you saw anybody they didn't
have all this other stuff you had to you
know fight off yellow fever all week and
dysentery and get everybody's butts
clean and everything and then wagging
them up to church and that's where you'd
see somebody and hope somebody would
with a little bit of money would make
love to your daughter or you know or you
know that's where you know that's where
it happened it all happened right there
on the you know and you know it's like
you know there is something strange
about because also I spent
my 20s and you know my 30s very much
opposed to it and then I married this
woman that that uh is Catholic and I
mean I was raised Catholic but kind of
just kind of culturally and but there is
something about there's a quietness
there
that you know there's something
meditative about it and maybe because
it's so boring but it was it's there is
something about like all right I'm just
standing there with my kids I'm just
sitting there with my kids it's
it's like the world slows down like I
you know you see why people go and why
they have a connection to it
yeah I love I mean I love Faith you know
I have I feel like I have a good faith
you know I like being able to close my
eyes and and I like to pray twice a day
I like to be able to think about God and
and and talk and or my God and ask him
you know what I can do for others and
just things like that or if I need help
to offer me some suggestion
um I love that kind of stuff I mean one
of the best times I've ever had in my
life or best I ever felt was when I felt
like I had a really strong connection to
a higher power yeah and I'd worked on it
a lot and it really came to fruition and
even if some people say well that's
Voodoo whatever it is doesn't matter it
worked it like I it worked as much as it
as it it was real as far as I knew and
if that's a if that's the truth to me
then that's great well it's also you
talk about you you had mentioned before
ego right like that humility
or just a concept of humility is so
necessarily right to navigate this
because if you let the ego take over hmm
it's trouble yeah I mean and I know yeah
I know that to some people listening
that we just sound like we're saying
gobbledygook but like it is one of those
like when you you know you're somebody
that if you you know like I've struggled
with my ego and stuff like that it's
like it's the only way you can get that
in line is having some humility and like
and the premise of religion that or
belief system that there's a higher
power
is is very kind of
it's like that's structurally
you know literally
puts you in a position of of humbleness
you know what I mean because you're
working with alongside somebody else or
for somebody else yeah yeah oh I'm so
grateful that there's something else out
there that I can believe because
yeah I think I like rejected the world
so much that I was in growing up that I
wasn't gonna take Direction
from anybody in it probably you know I
hated my environment so much I despised
like I mean I despised my [__]
environment you know it just I mean it
everything about it [__] hurt me I
felt like right that's how I felt anyway
yeah and so
no one in the world of human probably
would I ever
really believe in right so you almost
need this other this this uh satellite
to beam through this other entity to
help me get adjusted to trust
the world again and so that's why I'm
man because for me and everybody can
have their own thoughts I don't but for
me as long as they're the same as mine
I'm fighting with it but for me man I'm
so because I wouldn't believe you'd have
said Hey listen to this guy I don't know
if I would have done that but you give
me a a hype an invisible being right
yeah visually invisible
you know
and it's just and there's just enough
malleability in there for me to say okay
I'm well I'm willing to try this and
then it opens up more of a door for me
of like um of connection does that make
any sense yes I think also like even
saying I I I I think you know the whole
agnostic I don't know is
that's that's just where you got to be
you know I mean it's like it's like I
don't you know I think that human beings
are so arrogant and the assumption that
like every generation has thought that
they've had it figured out and every
generation has been wrong yeah you know
I mean like
even you know so it's like
if we can't be like we don't know okay
then we're really kind of starting from
a bad position
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one